that winner payoff from the name what
would you guess a repeater
does it ever pains that's helpful what
does it repeat DV Learning Network what
kinds of things could we repeat Dada
right okay so I wonder if you have seen
I'll see if I can find a picture for you
I wonder if you ever see yeah
that's not too bad okay so what's this
this is part of the Great Wall of China
okay so I don't know if you've ever seen
pictures like this before or see the
dramatized in movies these are really
high parts of the Great Wall of China
now I've always wondered like it's a
great it's a great wall right so it's a
huge so it's very very difficult to
build why does it Great Wall of China at
least in sections
it goes up mountains why is it gone
mountains if you want to fence off you
know bad guys right wouldn't you fence
off the part that's easiest to build
wall along right well you tell me why
did they build them on top of mountains
and part okay so I can't include you so
these parts of the war I'm not just
walls right but they're actually also
stations on top of each one is a huge
thing sort of like a lantern but on
steroids okay that if they wanted to
send a message
for instance that invasion was coming
right waited to do is light it and that
fire because of its size could be seen
at the next station right and then when
that signal when they like their signal
the next station considered and the next
one of the next one okay so what's going
on there's a signal at least in this
case it's very simple it just the signal
is I would fire okay
and it can be seen from very far away
and that signal gets repeated along a
long large distance okay now why there's
70 stations will there be like you know
dozens hundreds bit why should I be
oh I wish it down be good why does
certain stations I think you guys yeah
why don't just have like one station at
the place most likely to be mated and
then another station at the other end
where all the people are who are going
to read the message why all these ones
in between say it again but why do I
need your station people there finish ok
it's not quite like a it's not quite
like move on recession right okay
alright so your to give added military
chance but I'm just talking about the
signal I'm just talking other signal why
do I need so many oh yeah yeah right so
he's what we getting at all right um the
key idea is signalling signal strength
you can imagine right single straight if
you know the Mongols right just they
actually did invade China though I think
the great one wasn't really emplacement
but they do it the Mongols are evading
okay and so you know the guy the tower
says oh no they're raining quick set the
thing on fire okay now there was just
his station and then there was one in
you know major right um
they wouldn't be able to see that other
signal so far away because the light
wouldn't reach right because the signal
is not strong enough to reach that
distance or the same way if you have the
guy and your shadows up the vocals are
copy okay no one would hear him goes too
far away the signal lacks the strength
to make the distance okay
now even though we don't tend to think
about it signals on a network are
exactly the same it's not our sound and
it's not per se about light but you can
see there's some exceptions later on
it's my electrical signals right
electricity can't just travel along a
wire forever
why not what happens like if I had if I
had a wire right one end of a wire and
then I walked out the door and got on a
boat and sailed to the opposite end of
the Pacific right and then got off in
you know
Hawaii or something like yes it's a bit
of wine under wherever it is and then I
plug the Damned at the other end okay
why couldn't I just get really super
fast internet that way and just have
what cable that's coming across what can
I do it apart for the fact that it would
be ridiculous that such a long cable the
signal would go out the door through the
the side of the cable that's still here
with you but before it gets to my end on
the other side of the ocean right it run
out what would run out okay you guys go
study some physics this is covered in
you know that in science but I'll let
you guys revise it electricity right
it's actually lost as you go along the
way it's it's kind of like feet right in
that we don't have unless you've got a
superconductor you do research every
time we generally don't use materials
that can go along and not lose any other
electricity so if you're gonna transfer
your signal over a long distance it
needs to be repeated okay so what does
her appear to do here's the important
thing and a repeater is not just an
amplifier okay so it doesn't just take
whatever signal is received and it's
like oh it's a bit weak I'll just take
it and make it loud up okay
why do you think it wouldn't just do
that why not just amplify things as you
go along what what problems could creep
in if you did that
say yo DJ noise might accumulate what
noise do you mean what are you afraid to
because this is not an it's not an audio
signal winter electrical signal okay so
let's let's put a technical name that
shall we
interference interference I don't know
if you guys know how well you study your
science again but electricity is a force
of nature right it's actually just one
side of a force what's the other side we
call it the electro magnetic force
electricity and magnetism are really two
sides of the same coin
okay a magnetic fields they're
everywhere okay they're all around us
and so every way you've got magnetic
fields you've got things bucking around
with interfering with electrical signals
that you send okay so here's what
happens do you want say a 50 meter cable
okay and all around it there's going to
be sources of magnetism that are gonna
muck around with the electrical signal
so when your signal arrives it won't be
the same as when I left okay it'll be
softer because of last string but it
will also be actually changed and
different okay so won't do just to take
that old signal and make it louder
because if you do that you also make the
interference ladder okay so here's what
it does instead what it does is a
repeater reads the signal
okay and then it interprets it it
actually doesn't just say well
whatever's here I don't know I'll just
make it louder
it says well what does this signal
what's it likely you actually mean that
these zeros and ones what are they and
then it resets it says it afresh without
any of the interference which it thought
it might of detective okay so this does
is it preserves this signal as it goes
along
when you try to avoid this Chinese
whispers right Chinese whispers all
kinds of interference creeps in a bit by
the time you get to the other end it's
like what did they say I don't know it's
very unclear right so it's trying to
avoid that by rereading it every time
interpret okay okay so that's a repeater
what you've got the situation might be
you've got a load say note one over here
and if you have a long distance to get
to to get to another turn okay when you
have these repeaters along the way and
in fact when you go out and look if
you're uh if you're in a suburb like
mine where all of the power and
telephone lines are still above ground
they'd all like that West Penn Hills for
instance they're all below ground but I
live in a suburb where they're above
ground if you have a look at the
telegraph poles right have you ever
looked how the graph poll looks like
this okay and then it connects to
another one you've got a few cables in
between and it kicks to another one but
a lot of the telegraph pole there's like
all of this stuff hanging off and you're
like what do you call that I don't know
well at least one of the things that's
here is repeaters okay so make sure the
signal goes between different telegraph
poles and remains preserved and not
interfere okay